do you think nietzsche was on to
something with the idea
looking into the 20th century that god
is dead
that there is uh
a cultural distancing from a belief in
god
yeah you know i'd be so much sympathetic
to jordan peterson's reading of of
nietzsche there namely it's not
nietzsche crowing from the mountaintop
hey god is dead you know it's more of a
lament you know god's dead and we've
killed them
and
what will happen in the wake of that
and i think yeah much of the
totalitarianism of the 20th century
follows from that
that questioning of god and the
dismissal of god from from public life
so i would be sympathetic with that um
when we're beyond good and evil you know
and all that's left is the will to power
and then why are we surprised that the
powerful rise and that they use the
power less for their purposes
when we forget ideas like equality and
rights which are grounded in god why are
we surprised that that
death camps follow so i think there's a
correlation there for sure
i don't know i believe that there's a
capacity to do good in all of us
and a capacity to do evil and there's
something that tends towards good
whatever that is
i tend to think that if that community
that love that we talked about they find
each other they find
the good
if you don't constrain the resources if
you don't push them if you
don't artificially create conflict
through power centers and evil
charismatic leaders then people will be
good to each other and
whether that's god or some other source
of deep
um
moral meaning
that seems to be essential for
functioning civilization yeah and it's
hard i mean that's what humans are we're
searching for what that god is what that
means you know what that triggers in my
mind i wonder if you agree with this
that the modern sciences drew their
strength from their narrowness what i
mean there is is they almost completely
bracketed uh formal and final causality
in the aristotelian sense and they
focused on efficient and
material causality and that gave as i
say great strength but from the
narrowness of focus but for aristotle
the more important causes are the final
and the formal causes
and so final causality there what's
drawing us
so for aristotle he'd look at someone
like me and say okay
you're
you have a intelligible structure
and that leads you to seek certain
things for the perfection of that
structure you know
fair enough that's right so i seek the
good right now i'm seeking the good of
being with you i said yeah i'll sit down
with lex friedman and we'll talk about
deep and important things that's the
good i saw it this morning when i woke
up
now why am i seeking that well for a
higher
reason a higher good you know because i
it's part of my work my ministry is to
you know
the church reaching out beyond itself to
the wider culture and
okay why do you want that
well because i want to bring more and
more people into into the what i think
is beautiful and true and good in the
church well how come you want that
well because a long time ago i was kind
of myself brought into that realm and
find it very compelling yeah but then
why do you want that well because
ultimately i want to be i want to be
friends with god now i've given you one
example there but but
any act of the will it seems to me
has to be analyzed that way the will
seek something it seeks the good right
by definition but the good always nests
like a russian doll in in a higher good
right which then nests and is still
higher good
until you come this is aquinas to some
in this sense uncaused cause
an uncaused final cause there has to be
some sumumbonum right some supreme good
that you're looking for
uh and that's god by the way that's
another i think rational path to god is
is every single moment every day
we are implicitly seeking god
you